christian j'ai juste donné deux chiffres
à 300 millions d'armes à feu en
circulation aux états unis 30000
personnes tuées chaque année par une
arme à feu
on a senti est dans les commentaires de
barack obama de la colère de
l'exaspération aussi sur toute cette
question du contrôle des armes à feu
beaucoup de frustration vous avez raison
céline ce sera probablement la grande
déception de sa présidence lui qui avait
promis de régler ce problème
il n'aura pas réussi à restreindre la
vente et l'accès des armes à feu aux
états unis ne sais pas parce qu'il n'a
pas essayé rappelez vous immédiatement
après la tuerie de newton ou des petits
enfants de 5-6 ans juste avant noël
avait perdu la vie dans une école
primaire
le président avait tenté avec le congrès
de faire passer des lois pour limiter
l'accès aux armes et bien ce congrès à
majorité républicaine et même plusieurs
démocrates avaient refusé ces
changements à la loi
pourtant on pensait qu'après la mort
d'enfants ça allait se produire et ça
s'est pas produit c'est aussi un autre
coup dur pour la communauté noire
faisait allusion dans votre reportage
pour parler de racisme creissan et c'est
une question qui reste encore assez
tabou aux états unis
le racisme aux états unis céline c'est
l'éléphant qui est qui et dans la pièce
c'est le sujet dont personne ne veut
parler c'est le tiroir qu'on ne veut pas
ouvrir parce qu'on ne veut pas voir ce
qu'il ya à l'intérieur
pourtant il y en a du racisme aux états
unis il est parfois larvée il est
parfois ouverts contrairement à d'autres
pays comme l'afrique du sud le cambodge
et même le canada on a osé parler on a
osé reconnaître et dans certains cas
s'excuser face à certains peuples dont
on avait abusé alors les états unis
n'ont toujours pas fait ça la plaie du
racisme à plaies de l' esclavage est
encore trop vives
merci beaucoup christian je vous en prie
on l'évoquait plutôt cette église
méthodiste emmanuel est un lieu
emblématique dans l'histoire des noirs
américains
elle a été fondé par des esclaves à la
fin du xviiie siècle dans un état la
caroline du sud qui était un des
berceaux de l' esclavage
aux etats-unis elle a été détruite en
1822 en représailles un projet de
révolte fomenté par des esclaves dans
ses murs mais elle a été reconstruite
malgré l'interdiction des lieux de culte
pour les noirs plus tard après la lutte
pour l'émancipation des esclaves
l'église s'est distingué dans la lutte
pour les droits civiques de grandes
personnalités comme martin luther king
s'ils sont arrêtés au cours des années